there can be few journeys more painful
to make
survivors of this death camp coming to
lay reads
against the wall where thousands were
executed
the decades have not dimmed the memories
how could they
more than a million people were murdered
here gassed or shot
men women and children starved
experimented on
and killed ninety-year-old rini saltz
thinks this will probably be her last
journey back to auschwitz
the camp where she thought she too would
die she is afraid
what happened here will be forgotten
i get very very nervous every time i
come here
it's it's not that it reminds me because
i never forget what happened here
but i come here because
i want to show other people what
happened
to explain to them what happened here
200 survivors made the journey to
auschwitz for the 75th anniversary of
the camps liberation in 1945.
some sharing their memories at a
ceremony attended by world leaders
and royalty the polish president
speaking from the very spot where jews
arrived at the camp by trains
what came to be known as the gate of
death
hatred chauvinism nationalism
anti-semitism assume the form of a mass
and organized methodical murder
he said the truth about the holocaust
should never be allowed to die
his promise to nurture the memory of the
victims stirring emotion in men and
women
already finding this day difficult
they were here to remember yes but also
to do what they could
to make sure history is never repeated
i hope you all tried to preserve the
memory of this place and other sites
where people
innocent people died i hope that you
will bear this responsibility
so that this terrible thing will never
happen again
many spoke frankly saying they won't be
here much longer
to testify to the darkest of periods in
europe
but they have left an important legacy
in words
and warnings michelle clifford sky news
auschwitz poland